j'ai vu des enfants fumer dans les rues
en
Amérique j'en ai vu qui délirit sous
l'effet des
narcotiques j'ai vu des gangsters en
herbes et des criminels
verb pour oublier cette vie cette vie
qui les oublie il se donne du
[Musique]
vertige je vois des gens qui se grisent
avec des scènes de
violence dans l'alcool dans la bêtise un
peu partout même en
France ça m'affolle et ça
m'afflige j'y pense mon cœur se
fige parfois je n'y comprends rien et
pourtant je le sais bien moi aussi j'ai
mon
verti j'ai le
vertigege quand tu me dis je
t'aimee j'ai le
vertigege mais c'est pour
moi sur les routes on voit souvent des
gens plutôt pacifiques
devenir fou du volant c'est leur vin
c'est leur
mystique je ressens comme un
malaise comme au bord d'une
falaise je comprends et je l'ai plain
moi aussi je suis si bien quand je suis
dans mon
verti j'ai le
verestige quand tu me dis je t'aime
j'ai le
verig mais c'est pour
toi une fille et un garçon sur le bord
d'une
rivière deux amourux qui s'en vont c'est
un matin de
lumière et le regard d'un vieil
homme cette bonté qui rayonne
bonneur c'est simplement merveilleux ça
vous fait fermer les yeux ça vous donne
le
vertige j'ai le
vertigge tu me dis je
t'aime j'ai le
vertige mais c'est pour
toi j'ai le
verge quand tu me dis je
t'aime che le vertige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emporte-moi